c'était c'était le but du jeu essayer de
faire mieux que l'an dernier je me
battais après personne je me battais
contre moi contre mon temps et puis bah
voilà objectif atteint et c'est cool ça
a été dur l'ascension de la plaie très
très dur j'ai beaucoup souffert
voilà mais bon on aime ça en fait du
travail pour ça
le dépassement de soi et le plaisir
avant tout et est surtout un parcours un
parcours splendide
quels ont été les points sur lequel
justement tu as su aborder les choses
mieux pour améliorer ton temps justement
les descentes je suis plus à l'aise je
j'arrive à dérouler en descente en
gardant un peu plus un peu plus
d'énergie
voilà donc ce juste milieu là m'a fait
gagner du temps je pense et puis y'a pas
de secret c'est comme tous et pas que
dans le sport c'est le travail et le
travail le travail le travail et quand
on veut quelque chose bah faut se donner
les moyens s'étonne pas du ciel je
chante depuis démentent pour toi c'est
une vraie obsession je le garde pour moi
normalement mais oui tout à fait mais je
le garde faune voilà on je reste discret
là dessus on n'a pas besoin de s'étaler
voilà je fais mon truc je suis dans ma
bulle je prends plaisir je cours pour ma
famille aussi pour les rendre fiers pour
leur montrer que faut se battre
quoi qu'il arrive